- Just so great to see SOFCON
developing now to what it is.
I'm looking, I was just chatting with Sam,
who was one of our first
Special Operations students here
as a late career Yale College student,
and helped found this
Special Operations conference
at Yale in 2016.
And since then, under the leadership
of Ms. Skye and the support
of Mr. Kaplan, you know,
we've developed this PRK Fellows program
at the Jackson School for
Global Affairs at Yale,
which has really, helped bring
the special operations
community into contact
with the outstanding resources
that we have here on the Yale campus
and its teaching and research mission.
But I actually think
it's just as beneficial,
if not more for the students
who are not in that community.
And so to be able to learn
and interact with all of you
on the daily basis, you know,
the work that Mike and
his colleagues have done
in putting this conference together,
it's inspirational for our students.
It helps enhance the
public service mission
of what we're trying to do at Yale.
And it's been central to this effort
to build this Jackson School
of Global Affairs at Yale.
So it's the first new
school that Yale has created
in nearly 50 years since
our business school,
and reflects a real commitment
to putting challenges
and diplomacy and international
security, you know,
front and center at the
mission of the university
in really exciting ways.
I'm Ted Wittenstein.
I teach at the Jackson
School and at the law school,
and I oversee our international
security studies program
here at the Jackson School,
which includes what we now
call the Schmidt program
on artificial intelligence,
emerging technologies
and national empower.
And so thanks to Dr. Schmidt,
he has really helped resource
our teaching and learning
and interdisciplinary
approach to thinking about
how AI is changing the
nature of world order.
I see a number of students who are
in few of the classes that
me and other colleagues
teach at Yale in this space.
And it's hard because it's
such a rapidly changing field
and it's hard to predict even what
another six months of ChatGPT
X or something will bring
as the number continues to change.
And so part of what we're
trying to do is create
a greater technical fluency
among our non STEM students.
So how do we develop that
among our aspiring law policy leaders,
and then reverse because we
have so many STEM students
in our own courses and connected to us
around the Yale campus,
how do we develop that hybrid law policy,
ethical appreciation for
their research agenda?
How do we integrate that and maybe create
a model for a best
practice that might extend
as we think about pipeline challenges
in public service and some of the comments
that Mr. Innes was just making.
So we have an outstanding technology panel
to continue the conversation.
Really terrific expertise
both in the science
and technology of AI
and quantum computing.
I'll introduce Dr. Krishnan and
Dr. Girvin in just a moment.
And then we have some outstanding
private sector expertise as well
that I'm eager to incorporate.
And I'll introduce Mike Hayes
and Sam Hussain as we go.
But we'll try to keep
this interactive and fun.
So Dr. Krishnan is the WW
Cooper Ruth Cooper Professor
of Management Science
and Information Systems
at Carnegie Mellon University.
And he's dean of the Hines
College of Information Systems
and Public Policy at the
university since 2009.
He's been a faculty member as well
in engineering and public policy,
really embodies this
connection of hybrid tech
and policy fluency that
we need to grapple with AI
and the risks and opportunities.
He's a member of the National
AI Advisory Committee.
As many of you know, this
is a national level effort
to try to harness best
practices from academia
to inform government thinking.
So I wanted to start with some comments
from Dr. Krishnan on
how he thinks about AI,
both the risks and
opportunities in particular,
it's relevance to this audience.
I was struck, I liked Mr.
Innes's comments about
being wary of people
who try to sprinkle AI dust on everything.
And you've given a lot
of thought, Dr. Krishnan
into what it really means
to develop a full AI stack,
really the significant
components both from hardware
all the way through data and algorithms
to integration to human people.
And so just give us a sense
of how you think about
and scope this challenge.
What concerns you most about
the current environment,
but also what are some
of the opportunities
that you think might be of
relevance to this audience?
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
Thank you Ted.
Pardon the hoarseness of my voice.
I sort of seem to have allergies.
So thank you again for
the invitation to be here.
To Ash and to Ash Raja Ramen and to Mike
to invite me to come here.
It's been a great learning experience
listening to speakers this morning.
And as Ted was talking about
what Yale has put together
here with Special Operations Command,
we have a similar relationship
at Carnegie Mellon
with the US Army.
There's Army AI Center at Carnegie Mellon.
The Army Futures Command
sends officers for education
at Carnegie Mellon in AI.
And we also address senior
leadership one stars,
two stars on data-driven leadership.
And I can speak to that
as an important aspect
to the human capital aspects
associated with the discussion
that we've been having.
So Ted talked about the AI stack.
The AI stack is something
that Carnegie Mellon developed
to organize and frame the discussion
about the different
components of AI technology
that are relevant to how
it's gonna be deployed,
be it commercially,
be it in government,
be it in to address the kinds of questions
that we are hearing about today.
And it ranges, and it in some ways,
for those of you who are
very familiar with the ODA
or ODA stack, the observe, you know,
each of these different
elements of that stack,
the AI stack is sort
of organized similarly.
At the bottom layer is the
sensing or perception layer.
And increasingly that
layer is in hardware.
And this is about audio, video,
multimodal text based perception.
And those signals that are perceived,
that's equals to the
observation, the ODA stack.
And that perception then feeds
into a signal processing layer,
which tries to make sense
of what's being actually perceived.
And then that then feeds
into this learning layer.
And for a long, long time now,
I mean there's been
tremendous developments
in the learning stack, which in itself,
as you know, has had
tremendous amount of progress,
particularly in the field of deep learning
and neural network architectures.
Everybody's been excited
about what's happened
since the release of ChatGPT
and these so-called large language models.
They are all at the learning layer
of being able to take
vast amounts of corpora.
So for instance, ChatGPT 4
was trained on 570 gigabytes
of text and other kinds of corpora bit,
code from GitHub, be it images
from Getty Images, video.
So it's this immense amount of input
that's gone into the training
of these neural networks.
And these models have
grown in size as well,
the ChatGPT 4 has what's
called 170 billion parameters
in the neural network.
So that learning layer
as the size of the training corpora
and the size of these
models have increased,
the capacity and the
capabilities of these models
ranges from the kinds of capabilities
you've seen exhibited by ChatGPT.
And ChatGPT is one of many
large language models.
Google has something called Bard.
And there's lots of different
kinds of powerful models
that are being developed by organizations.
I was at an emerging tech
event a couple of weeks ago,
and Adobe has its own large language model
for images and video.
And increasingly you're seeing
the integration of these learning layers
and the output of those capabilities
in personal productivity tools,
be it the Microsoft stack,
as Microsoft has announced,
or Adobe or Google Mail, et cetera.
The learning stack then feeds into
a decision making layer.
So what is it that's been learned?
How can it actually
support decision making
where you're using the patterns
that have been learned
on importantly even potentially
causally understanding
the relationships between
what's being observed
and what decision to take.
And this is where it
could be a very useful
decision support device,
particularly to the human.
And this is the human, the loop,
but it could equally well potentially
support decision making autonomously,
that's the decision making layer.
The decision making
layer then on top of that
recedes the action layer.
So the stack then at a very minimum,
you could think of it as
having these four layers,
the perception layer, the learning layer,
the decision making layer
and the action layer.
And these different layers can be deployed
via the enterprise.
It can be deployed at the edge,
conditional on the
constraints of the technology.
Imagine a large language model.
Today I don't think we have the devices
to actually deploy it
directly on a mobile device,
because it takes immense amount
of compute and data power
to train these models, but once trained
could you imagine an image of these models
that could be put on a device,
that could be on a disconnected,
not connected to the network,
not the way we use
ChatGPT today with an API,
but imagine it being on a
mobile device disconnected,
that could potentially change the nature
of the deployment and the edge
for the kinds of use cases
that were being discussed earlier today.
And the nature of these capabilities,
if you think of this is
what I've described entirely
is a technology stack
and an associated set of capabilities.
The biggest challenges have been
how do you get people
trained with the skills
to be able to effectively
use this technology stack.
So just to give you an
example of something.
We work like I said with the US Army,
they send us AI technicians,
there's technician training,
they are officers being trained
for being data engineers
or data scientists.
And then the leadership has to understand
how best to put this
trained human capital to use
in the field using this technology.
If you train these folks
and then put them back to work
doing exactly the same
old thing they did before
they did the training,
that's not much point.
And therefore the futures
command training set,
if you think of this as a pyramid,
at the top end of the pyramid
are the PhDs and the masters,
then come a very large number of people
who are gonna be deployers.
And then there are lots of operators.
That's the AI technicians,
the officers being data
sciences and data engineers
plus people who are actually
gonna create the tech.
So you need a very holistic view,
and I think of this as
a human capital stack
that has to stand side by side
with the technology stack
to actually get the
most value out of this.
So let me stop here Ted,
and I'm sure there'll
be lots of opportunities
to build on this discussion.
- All right, thank you so much.
I'm gonna try to save
myself and all my questions
for just a minute 'cause
I wanna incorporate
some of the other expertise that we have.
So just shifting from AI for
a moment to quantum computing,
I was also struck by Mr. Innes's
comments about, you know,
just the challenge of grappling
with emerging technologies
with unclear time horizons and impact,
and quantum computing strikes me
as an area where this is a
particularly acute challenge.
So very grateful to
have Dr. Girvin with us.
He's been a member of the
Yale faculty since 2001.
He's the Eugene Higgins
professor of physics
and applied physics.
He's had some significant
university administration roles
here including as deputy
provost for research,
kind of overseeing Yale's
overall strategic planning
and resource allocation
and personnel decisions
with respect to the sciences across Yale.
And he returned to full-time
teaching at Yale in 2017.
But that's not all that he does.
He is of course himself
an exceptional scholar
in the theoretical studies of
quantum many particle systems.
He's been part of setting up
the Yale Quantum Institute,
which is a really significant effort,
which is sort of developing
a practical architecture
for construction of a quantum computer,
which has one numerous
acclaim both nationally
as well as around the world.
And in addition to his teaching,
he was the founder and still is a member
of the Center for Quantum Advantage,
which is part of the
Brookhaven National Laboratory
and a Department of Energy funded effort
to try to harness a
better national approach
to understanding both the risks
as well as the opportunities
that quantum computing might hold.
So Steve I wanted to bring
you into the conversation
with respect to quantum.
You know this is an audience
with varying levels of
knowledge about this
promises as well as all sorts
of hyperbole perhaps as well
that's been thrown out there before.
So maybe help us think about
what you see as the most
significant applications
of quantum computing
and their national security implications,
both benefits and risks
and what a military audience should know
and start thinking about as
you grapple with the timelines
and your outstanding
research in this area.
- Sure.
Thanks very much Ted.
So you guys have been throwing
a lot of acronyms at me today,
so I feel like I should start with
a little bit of vocabulary
and maybe some historical context
about what is this all about.
So, you know, one of the
main pillars of physics
is classical mechanics.
The theory of invented by Isaac Newton
more than 300 years ago that determines
the orbits of satellites and missiles,
the orbit of the moon and so forth.
It's fantastically successful theory,
but it only applies to
sort of large objects.
Something goes wrong when you get down
to the scale of individual
atoms or individual electrons.
And we needed a new theory
beginning about a hundred years ago,
the quantum theory was invented
and that led to what I'll call
the first quantum revolution
beginning a century ago that
brought us the transistor,
the laser, and the atomic
clock, which led to GPS.
And the entire 20th century
technology revolution was built
on these first quantum devices,
but there's now a second
quantum revolution underway.
It has huge promise,
maybe a lot of hype for sure,
very uncertain timelines,
but it has the potential to be possibly
as big a revolution as
the one that brought us
the 20th century tech revolution.
And it's based on not a
new theory of quantum,
but a new understanding of
this a hundred year old theory
and the role of information
content in quantum states.
And we now realize that
the transistor, the laser
and the atomic clock
while quantum machines,
they don't harness the full power
that is actually available
in quantum machines
and quantum technology.
And so the sort of three use cases
that are relevant to this
audience are quantum sensing.
It turns out in the quantum theory,
you have to think deeply
about what is a measurement,
what is detecting something.
And it's more complicated and subtle
than in classical physics,
because when you measure
something it changes.
But it's important to you
for the detection of
extremely weak signals.
Small magnetic anomalies near
overhead above submarines,
gravitational anomalies
over caves and mountains,
weak radio signals, et cetera.
The kind of quantum limited amplifiers
that we build for our quantum
computers could easily,
they work in cell phone frequency ranges.
They can easily detect
or perhaps even be overloaded
by a cell phone on the moon.
The second is quantum
encryption and communication.
Current cryptographic protocols
are more or less uniformly
based on the difficulty
of some math problem,
solving some math problem.
Quantum encryption security is based on
our inability to violate
the laws of physics.
It's a different setup.
And then finally, quantum computation.
The ability to process information
in completely new ways
compared to traditional,
what I'll call classical computers.
It's a completely new
model of computation.
Certain problems which
computer scientists classify
as difficult or exponentially hard
as you raise the size of some database
are not necessarily exponentially hard
if you can build a quantum computer.
Their advantages do not come from having
a faster clock speed.
Often the clock speed, at least today,
is slower than the highly developed
rap fast classical
computers we have today.
But it's a completely different model,
which for certain classes of problems
that can be solved more
readily on quantum hardware.
So for example,
you only need a few thousand quantum bits
to do something extremely
interesting and powerful
with a quantum computer.
You don't need the kind
of scale of terabytes
and things that you have
in today's computers.
On the other hand, we
don't even have that yet.
We're in a very early
stages of the technology.
The technology is imperfect,
makes lots of errors.
The number of calculations we can do
or calculational steps we can do
before an error happens is very small.
A few thousand perhaps today.
So a grand challenge is to figure out
how to do error correction.
We also need to have a
greater understanding
of what kind of algorithms
can be invented,
what kind of problems can be solved
more efficiently with this hardware.
We understand something
about optimization problems
and simulation problems
and machine learning
classification problems
and things like that.
But I wanna be very clear,
I've heard a lot about big
data and high data rates
and things that probably big data problems
and machine learning problems,
while in principle there
are quantum advantages
that will be the last area of application
for technical reasons that we need
for exponentially big data sets,
we actually need exponentially
many quantum bits
and we just don't have those yet.
In terms of timeline quantum sensing
and quantum encryption are here now.
I mean there are even companies
you can purchase from,
but with lots of limitations
in terms of bandwidth
`and lack of being portable
or battle hardened and so forth.
But the technology is here.
Computation, I don't know.
I've been saying at least
10 years for a while now.
Given that the people who
invented the transistor,
the laser and the atomic clock
had no idea what they
were gonna be used for
I hesitate to say where this
is going or how quickly.
And so I'm reasonably sure
they're gonna be, you know,
just as there were AI winters,
they're gonna be quantum winters.
But I'm somewhat optimistic
that the government is presently taking
a pretty sensible all
of government long term
coordinated approach to
investing in this research area.
So as long as they continue
that and are patient,
I think this is going to lead to
really interesting new technologies.
Exactly in what form and what
the best use cases will be,
that's the future of which
I'm still unsure about.
- [Ted] Great.
Thank you so much.
I'll come back to you with some questions
and I'm sure the audience
has their own as well.
So turning to this question
then of how to incorporate
and adapt emerging technologies
into business operations,
would really like to get
Mike Hayes's thoughts on this
and reactions both to
the technical discussion
we just had on AI and Quantum
as well as Mr. Innes's comments before.
Mike Hayes is VMware's
Chief Operating Officer.
I think many of you are
familiar with VMware.
It's one of the world's leading
cloud computing companies,
valuation of over $60 billion.
And in that capacity, you know,
he's responsible for
worldwide business operations,
passion for sort of driving
agility and excellence
in the customer mission as well,
which I'm sure we'll hear about.
Prior to joining the private sector,
Mr. Hayes spent 20 years
in the US Navy seals,
multiple combat tours in Bosnia, Kosovo,
Iraq and Afghanistan at some
significant command levels
as well as some White
House policy experience,
director for defense policy
and strategy at the
National Security Council.
And I'll just put a plug
for his best selling book as well,
"Never Enough: A Navy Seal Commander
"Living a Life of Excellence,
Agility and Meaning"
and I'm putting a plug
because he donates all profits
to pay off the mortgages
for gold star families,
in which I think you're on the seventh,
it's what you mentioned to me just now.
So Mike, I'm interested in your reactions
from where you sit now at VMware
and overseeing such a significant
cloud computing company
just on the verge of this next level
of data processing revolution,
but also having the public sector
and the military service
that you've also had
and those experiences of
inhabiting both those worlds.
So thank you for being with us.
- Ted. Thank you for having me.
First of all, after listening
to Dr. GIrvin and Krishnan,
I'm not sure I'm at the right conference.
These guys are way smarter
and I'm humbled to be here.
I'm just a simple guy who's
wearing a coat kerchief
in his pocket for the first
time in his 52 year life.
So, you know, I got this for Christmas
and tried it out today on all of you.
So anyways, that makes me
super nervous to be here.
Hey, thanks to Yale seriously
for putting this on.
A couple of quick thoughts.
Look, I'm just a simple guy
that thinks about things
in a very simple way.
I think the art form of really
thinking about technology
is how do you make
complicated things simple?
And for me, when I'm
running the, you know,
global operations for VMware,
I really think about
things in a couple ways.
First of all, what I would say is,
technology is awesome,
but keep in mind that
technology is a means to an end.
And so technology is just
driving and creating value.
And so just like when
you're in the military
on an operation, and one of
the things we got better at
post 9/11 was working backward
from the outcome we were
trying to achieve, right?
It wasn't like, oh my gosh,
I wanna go on a mission
and let me go put all
this training to work,
whether no matter what part
of the military you're in,
it's what effect are we trying to cause
and then how do we take
the least amount of risk
along the way so that
we can go achieve that.
That's no different at VMware.
And see if you think about
the product development life cycle,
like right now we spend four
plus billion dollar a year
in research and development.
And how do we think about how
we spend our own economics?
It's not complicated.
There's a market for something
that we're trying to achieve.
How do we as an
organization coalesce around
the what we are trying to do?
And from there then it gets to the how.
So if the vision is the where,
the strategy is really the how.
And what matters a lot
to me is to think about
not me working another two
or another 26 hours a day
that's not gonna move
the needle on anything.
I'm in charge of a system.
And so when I think about a system,
technology is a key part of it
but you also have to
have process and policy.
And so what it takes is
somebody to step back
and be able to put together
and do the systems-based
thinking to unlock the value
that's in your organization.
For example, you know,
when I'm a commander of a
special operations task force
and in the talk or the jock
or whatever you wanna call it,
you know, I walk in and I've intentionally
designed myself out of a job.
Why?
That's who I can sit there
and think about the negative space,
not the positive space
of what's happening.
Everybody's already gravitating toward
what their job is already
in the negative space.
That's where all of the
opportunity and the risk is.
So when I walk into a Fortune
500 company now and I say,
who here is in charge of
what we are not doing?
It doesn't compute because
people aren't thinking about
that negative space.
And so when you think
about creating a system,
how do you systematically
go after opportunities
and value creation in that negative space?
You know, for me, one of
the things that enjoyed
from Bill's presentation was
really the crystallization,
and I'm gonna overly simplify here,
but if you think about the COCOMs,
they are driving outcomes.
And when you think about
functional providers
like a SOCOM or any
sort of unit in the US,
you are truly providing a capability.
And so think about the world
when you do the AI pixie dust,
what's the outcome
you're trying to achieve
or what's the function that
you're trying to maximize,
but be really crisp and
laser-like in your thinking around
what are you doing and why?
And so for me, I think that's
what really breaks down a lot
is the governance and the systemization
of what you're doing.
'Cause VMware has 40,000 employees,
and so if we don't get the system right,
then we're gonna fail, and
so what does that mean?
Go back to Bill's presentation.
And when you look at you
know, from satellites to subs
and you think about the points in between
you are creating, there is a system there.
And so sure any single node in that system
is important, but way,
way, way more important
is the architecture of that system.
And so if you think about architecture,
how does information flow back and forth
across a system so that any single node
can underperform,
an individual fails but
the organization doesn't.
And so as we think about these great,
you know, quantum compute, AI, et cetera,
what to me is really important
is having the architecture right.
And I'm a little biased because
I mean at VMware and that's what we do.
But you think about how do you enable
an organization to have a
really clean application layer?
How do you have a really clean data layer?
And you know, one of the things
that I've just overseen
is the complete rebuild
of our entire enterprise's
data foundation.
We have structured and unstructured data.
How do you get the most out of that?
Well, you know, running a
transformation for a fortune,
you have Fortune 500 company,
it's not sexy to go say
hi, we're gonna go fix the data
because your sales teams and your product,
you know, engineers, et cetera,
they don't see the oil
that is in the engine
and that makes the car go.
And so what I really
would encourage people
to think about is really
the underlying system
because if you don't get
that foundation right,
then anything else is a capability
whether it's OnPrem with
a hyperscaler on the edge,
sitting with an MSP, wherever you are,
that is really a function
of your foundation.
So my point is, you know, always prepare
for the thing that you can't see coming.
And so when you're writing
requirements think about,
to Ted's point, think about building
agility into your system
because by the time
something comes to life,
there will be a million more use cases
you didn't think of from when
you wrote the requirements.
And so did you create
something that is fluid
and functional that can be not just used
for a point in time,
but to be used for, you know,
many, many years to come.
So it's a relatively simple point,
but it's one that often gets missed.
- [Ted] Great. Thanks so much Mike.
I wanna bring in Sam as well,
of course also one of our Yale graduates.
So it's great to have him back.
As I mentioned before at the beginning
as one of our late career
Yale undergraduate students,
what we call our Eli Whitney students.
Sam came from the special
operations military community
to Yale for a late year BA,
and has since gone on to
utilize that background
for some of the incredible
work that he's doing
in strategy and growth consulting.
He is currently corporate
strategic growth director
from Peraton Corporation.
And there he's managing
the growth of about
a $12 billion enterprise pipeline
that's trying to create US
government opportunities
in defense space intelligence, cyber,
civilian and health sectors of the firm,
managing a lot of complex strategies
and operations in this regard.
And in particular and in perspective
that maybe is a little
bit different than Mike's
is working with the startup
community as well in the AI
and emerging tech space.
So I wanted to maybe bring
in your thoughts on that.
We've talked about the talent pipeline,
the acquisition challenges,
what is sort of some of
the principle challenges
confronting startups in this space,
particularly as you think about
their potential application
to the defense industrial base,
and then still having the major players
as well who are established.
But you know, there's a role
for integrating new approaches as well.
So how do you scope and
think about that challenge
and what do you think is most relevant
for this audience?
- No, thank you Ted.
And it's wonderful to
be back here of course,
but before I begin,
I just wanna give a big shout out to Mike
for putting all this thing together.
I know it required a lot of hard work
because I've been there brother.
So no, thank you.
So I just wanna give a--
(audience applauding)
(Mike speaking faintly)
Thank you so much.
And Ted you and the leadership
here at Jackson as well,
thank you for keep on hosting these events
as far as this so crucial
for our national security
to have this engagements happen every year
to really get that going.
And you know, there's the
thing that I'm seeing right now
in Washington is that
the need for innovation,
every command, every PO,
everybody is coming to the
industrial base and saying,
"Hey guys, give us real innovation.
"We don't want the repackaged solutions
"that you guys have offered
for the last 20 years,
"what is happening?
"Where is this innovation coming from?"
And one of the things that
I've been leading is really
the outreach to the startup communities,
companies, two, three man operations,
brilliant computer scientists
quantum physicists, et cetera,
that are trying to do
business with the government
but don't have a cage code,
don't have a facility clearance.
How do you get involved
with working with the Pentagon or the IC?
So, you know, there's many companies
that are leading those initiatives
and I have to say the Pentagon's
done a great job with DIU
and establishing an office down
in the valley and everything
which is moving the needle
but not fast enough.
So we are actively looking at firms
that can provide solutions,
neat solutions to really sit on that
overarching capability
set that is affecting us
like near peer and all this
other stuff that's happening,
but also the unexpected type
of issues that are arising.
Just these days, I mean recently we saw
the balloon fiasco that was happening
across Montana and everywhere
and everybody was like,
how can this happen that a Chinese balloon
is able to come into
our airspace, et cetera.
Hey, you know, that's what
electronic warfare's all about.
What are we doing about creating
those electronic force fields, et cetera.
There's a lot of research going on,
and I'm currently working
with the good folks
at Georgia Tech Research Institute.
They're doing some great work out there
and that's actually being implemented
at certain areas with FSOC, et cetera.
But this engagement is
also morphing as well
where we're seeing so many threats evolve
and the next generation,,
or the current generation of operators
need to be hybrid trained in my opinion.
They need to have core
capabilities, not expert level,
but at least conversational
level at osen, at even human.
I'm a human guy and I
think it's very important
when you're out in the field,
if you're disconnected,
you can still function and
sustain in that environment
individually, and that is very crucial.
That is something that I'm very pushing on
with the folks down in Tampa and Bragg,
and I really wanna see
those expertise develop
and be trained for the
operator so they're never
dependent on one individual
back at the HQ level.
But at the same time,
I wanna say that all the
stuff that's happening about
AI and ML and everything,
that's all great,
but we should not forget the
basic fundamentals as well.
Human is key, I'm gonna
put a plug in for human
just because we saw this
in the '90s and the '80s,
just because as the '80s
we were launching all these
satellites and everything.
Hey no problem, we can see
anything from anywhere, great,
but we could then tap
into the terror networks
in Philippines, et cetera, in
Pakistan, Afghanistan areas.
So we need to keep that capability alive,
but at the same time we
need to increase and reduce
this talent train that we're experiencing
within the NASA community,
that we need to recruit individuals
and recruit the next generation,
and not just talk about, okay,
hey, we're gonna recruit from
these communities, et cetera,
but also be competitive about it, right?
And include, you know, there's a thing
I give incentivize but also expedite,
Facebook or Google gives an offer letter
and you start Monday.
Clearance level at the
NSA is gonna take a year,
That kid is not waiting,
they're not waiting and
we're losing individual,
we're losing talent that way.
And that is a big concern right now.
I was sitting with Rob Joyce not long ago
and I was like, sir, you
know, we have to pick this up.
We have to have programs at colleges
that are immediate hires
that are helping be the next
coding or mathematicians,
et cetera at the National Security Agency
because it's so crucial,
and it's something that
is very concerning.
But on the tech side,
specifically speaking,
one thing that I'm very
excited about is space.
All the stuff and activity
that's happening in space these days,
just on Sunday we launched
the first trench program that's happening.
CubeSats, they're amazing.
I think that's going to be a game changer
with the ISR platforms
to provide that continuous monitoring
that's going in a hybrid platform,
in a hybrid model where you
are looking at a target,
but also you can launch assets to,
it doesn't require long flyovers,
et cetera within the Indo
Paycom region specifically.
But these are exciting new technologies
that are being developed.
But at the same time,
all technology is great,
but if we don't have the people
that are out there to execute
these amazing technologies,
that's a problem.
And that is something we
need to keep that in mind.
Yeah, please.
- [Ted] Thank you so much.
I'm ask a follow up to folks here,
and then we'll incorporate
all of your comments as well.
Dr. Krishnan I want to zoom back in on
maybe one or two of the
layers that you focused on,
namely at decision making and
action with respect to AI.
Because we did have a question
from Mr. Bergen earlier
about human in the loop, right?
And so of course the Department of Defense
has this new revised directive now
on automation and this
concept of meaningful control.
And so, you know, just
based on your own research
and teaching and the programs
that you're building at CMU, you know,
what's the right way to
think about this question
of human in the loop?
We throw around so many of
these terms a lot on AI,
responsible use, ethical
use, meaningful control,
you know, what are some of the
best practices in your view,
in this space that are most
relevant for this audience,
which may be ultimately
hoping to utilize AI
in human machine teams to make
significant kinetic decisions.
And so just give us some
thinking on this question.
I think that might be
Particularly helpful.
- Thank you.
It was on actually.
Thank you Ted.
So two things to keep in
mind more broadly about AI
is the technology, even
though from what you read,
you might think it's some magic button
that will work perfectly all
the time in all situations,
that's not the case.
It's really good
oftentimes on narrow tasks,
that's where it's been shown
to be particularly good.
And it's oftentimes brittle
when you start deviating from the data
on which it was trained on.
This is called drift.
There's this idea that
you train a model on data
and if what you're seeing in the world
is not representative of
what it was trained on,
you might not get good
recommendations, good decisions.
So one is to recognize that
robustness, brittleness,
these are things to be
really well educated about.
So it's almost like having
what these are often called
data cards or model cards
where for every AI there's a
need to have metadata about,
you know, in what range is
this AI to be totally trusted,
what's the confidence
interval, if you will,
around this AI that's sort
of an important aspect.
Now, given the consequential
of the decision
that you need to make,
I mean, if it's about popping
an ad on somebody's computer,
and if the AI made a
mistake in showing you an ad
that you're unhappy with,
that's not super consequential.
But on the other hand,
if it's a consequential
decision that has to do
with people's lives,
or the kinds of services
you're providing them,
or in even where people's
lives are at stake
and the kinds of situations
that you all are engaged in
those tasks the bar is very
high in terms of ensuring
are the values that we as a society,
you as an organization have articulated.
And this is where the
responsible use part comes in.
So you have accuracy,
effectiveness, efficiency,
you want the war fighter
to be better equipped
to be able to make these decisions
and gain situational awareness,
be able to deal and digest data
that's coming at a rate
that without the support
they're not able to provide,
All of that is on the
plus side of the column.
On the negative side
of the column might be
how do I trust what it is
that this thing is producing
and how do I ensure that what
it is that is producing is
a, been validated, verified, et cetera.
And two are there in the societal setting,
in domestic societal setting,
these are often referred
to in terms of, you know,
ensuring equity, or in this
case it might have to do
with ensuring that the values
that you have to sort of
balance are taken into account.
So oftentimes, let me give you
a societal example I'm familiar with.
One might be asked to make a trade off.
So oftentimes a trade off in
AI governance that arises is
how much are you willing
to trade off on accuracy
to get an additional unit of equity?
And in your case you replace
equity with, you know,
the appropriate dimension
that you are concerned about
or vice versa, can I get more of both?
Can I be more accurate and more equitable,
or is there really a trade off?
And if I'm gonna make that trade off,
what are the weights that
people are gonna place
on these things and who
comes up with these weights?
Is there guidance and doctrine
that's gonna tell you
that this is how you're gonna
have to make these trade offs?
So I think the high level
point that I wanna make
is irrespective of whether
it's generative AI,
the ChatGPT like technology,
which makes a lot of errors.
It's not perfect by any means,
but it does move the
needle on a number of tasks
that you might be
interested in using it for,
so that's the accuracy or efficiency
or effectiveness under the dimension.
You're always asking the
question by deploying this AI
when can I trust it?
So this is the part about
validity verification, et cetera.
And then when I actually use it,
how can I use it in a way
where it's in aligned with my values?
And that's where this trade
off governance question
comes up between improving
accuracy and efficiency
and this equity point that I made.
The larger point that you
oftentimes see firms making
this decision about
when they deploy AI is,
I think Mike made the point
that at the end of the day
all of this is means to an
end it's absolutely true.
Let me give you example from healthcare.
In healthcare they take
the system as a whole,
I don't care about whether
this algorithm is fair
or accurate or whatever,
oftentimes it's a pipeline.
I'm interested in the performance
of the system as a whole.
And in healthcare there's something called
the quintulpe aim.
There are five dimensions
along which you rate
any healthcare delivery system.
Is the patient doing better?
Is the provider doing better?
Is the community doing better?
And those dimensions, those
are called the quintuple aims
of any healthcare system.
Might be useful to think about,
is there the equivalent of
a quintuple aim like that,
should there be something
that should guide,
which is multiple
criteria that should guide
the assessment and evaluation
of AI-based systems
when AI is deployed in
the kinds of context
that you're working with.
And responsible use comes down to
how do I play with the parameters,
who's empowered to do that one?
And two how can I assess
and evaluate the system
in terms of the objectives,
and the aims that matter to me most.
So that's how I think about it.
- [Ted] Great, thank you so much.
Steve. I think we're
still a little bit off
from the use of quantum computing for life
or death decision making of the sort
that this audience is accustomed
to making on a daily basis.
But you know, we are
still not that far away
from being able to scope what
some of the risks might be.
And so just give us a sense of
what does concern you most
from the national security perspective?
Is it the loss of secure communications?
There's obviously a lot
of hyperbole surrounding
whether other nations
might develop in this area.
China of course has a very
aggressive national quantum plan.
I'm curious if you have any thoughts on
China's own activity in this space
that might be of relevance
to this group that's possibly
really the only nation level
state capable of competing.
Are the threats in your
mind sort of specific
in terms of what some
of the impacts could be,
or is it more this general fear
of kind of a loss of
national competitiveness
as a new next generation technology
enters the scene a decade from now?
- Yeah, thanks Ted.
So China is indeed investing heavily.
It's very hard to say from the outside
how efficiently et cetera.
I mean lots of, just as in this country,
many things have been relabeled quantum
to seek funding from the government.
I know that's true in China.
But they're investing very heavily.
In terms of communication and encryption,
there's sort of offense and defense
and quantum contribute
to both sides in the end.
If all of this can be made to work well
privacy is enhanced
because there are forms
of quantum communication such that even
an adversary with quantum capabilities
will be unable to break the encryption.
On the other hand,
a lot of current encryption
is based on the difficulty
of solving certain mathematical problems
without knowledge of a key
or other crib to get in.
And it's perfectly possible
and presumably is going on
that much of this encrypted
communication is currently being
captured and written to disks
and could be decrypted using
quantum hardware when...
We're not close to being able
to apply shore's algorithm
to do this, for example now,
but could happen within,
you know, 10 or 20 years.
So there's a lot of interest
in what's called post quantum encryption.
It's classical ordinary
mathematical encryption,
but with the different
algorithms that are designed
to be difficult even
for quantum computers.
So there's a lot of concerns,
I guess both on offense and defense
connected with this technology.
The players in the world are China,
the US and a few countries in Europe,
Switzerland, Germany,
Austria, Sweden primarily.
And I think it's very important
to take a long-term view of
sort of national investments
in this just because
it's extremely uncertain.
There isn't the guaranteed payoff,
but we need to be,
you know, if there is a breakthrough,
we need to have the workforce
and the technical expertise and the people
and the ecosystem to
really respond to that.
- Could I make one comment--
- [Ted] please, yes
- by what Steve said.
In all the things that I said
about responsible use of AI,
one of the things to keep in
mind is that the adversary
may not be responsible.
So when you think about that setting,
what would it take by way of technology,
by way of human capital,
by way of systems that we have,
that would allow for us
to compete and out-compete
an adversary who might be irresponsible.
That's a good framing for
us to think about as well.
- [Girvin] That's very good.
- [Ted] Thank you.
Mike I wanted to get your thoughts
on one other area that
Mr. Janice touched on,
which was cybersecurity
and supply chain security in particular.
Obviously managing such a vast
cloud computing enterprise
as you do, you know, the
attack surface is vast, right?
The adversaries seem to
be growing in capability,
diffusing in capability
from the most sophisticated state actors
to a wide range of kind of gray actors
or even non-state actors in this space.
So emerging technologies including AI
of course have the ability both to
accelerate the cybersecurity concerns,
but also maybe hold out some
opportunities for detection
and mitigation and building resilience.
And just kind of curious how you grapple
with this challenge
from your vantage point
in sort of both the risk
as well as the benefit.
- Ted, it's a great question.
Like you heard, I spent some time in DC
so I'm really good at
not asking the question.
I was not answering the
question I was asked,
but the question that I wish I was asked,
we'll come back to the cyber thing.
I think there's an elemental
point to what you're saying
that is universally applicable to whether
it's cyber or any other technology.
You know, if you think back
when the bicycle was invented,
parents got really nervous that their kids
were gonna be able to go too far away
and they were losing control.
You know, most of us in this room remember
we started navigating
when we learned to drive
with Rand McNally maps
and now we're on Waze.
If it's map and compass,
I was a silver ranger and grid square guy
and now everybody else is using
these little handheld GPSs instantly.
You know we always have
a little bit of nostalgia for the past,
at the same time you can't
live without the present.
And so if you think about
the universal truths of
technology advancement,
there's always a little bit of,
oh no, we can't let go of the past,
but we can't live without the present.
And so that's a really
important thing to remember
that as we're talking about models,
to Peter's point earlier around like,
the previous discussion around
when will the computers
be doing everything
and we just be watching,
you know, that is coming.
If you really think
about what are we doing,
think about the world
in three simple layers.
You've got data, you've got logic,
and then you've got an
opinion or a decision.
And so you very crisply
need to separate your data
and your logic and your opinion,
and all you're really doing mostly is
unpacking logic and digitizing it.
You know when I was the commander
of special operations task
force southeast, 2000,
people running everything
in southeastern Afghanistan in 2012.
I personally was responsible
for 1100 times clearing,
you know, 500 pound JDMs from aircraft
to drop on a ground.
So now all I'm doing is
a decision making system.
And so if you really think about it,
all I'm doing is unpacking logic
of when to say yes and
when to say no, that is...
Dr. Krishnan and Dr.
Girvin could program that
in a split second.
All we need to do is get
from like what's happening,
not just in my brain, but
in my unit's collective
brain and getting that down.
That is very replicable.
Now the thing is with model
drift to Dr. Krishnan's point,
you have to be very careful
because at some point
there will be wrong decisions.
And so when there...
We won't be defined whether or not
there are wrong decisions,
we will be defined by how we
handle the wrong decisions.
That's the most critical piece.
Just like if we ever did
something wrong with a,
and I'm proud to say we
never harmed anybody,
we shouldn't harm on those
1100 air to ground drops.
But let's just say we did, you know,
how do you diagnose down to the root cause
what the failure was?
That feedback is not different
than the product that
we're developing at VMware.
There's a product for
VMware's for our products,
excuse me, a market for our products.
There's product market fit.
You have gaps in between where we are
and where we wanna be for the market.
And then, oh, by the way,
the market's always moving.
How do we systematically get after that?
Well, sometimes we're wrong.
A lot of times we're wrong.
But as long as we're right
more than we're wrong,
that's okay, will we be defined
with how we handle the wrongs?
The wrongs have to feed
back into that loop.
So with cyber, look, we're gonna have,
I ran two and a half billion dollar PNL
for financial services at Cognizant
before being at VMware.
We had a ransomware attack
where everything was shut down.
And when UBS is calculating
their end of day PNLs
at every desk and then
rolling it up to the PNL
for the whole firm and saying,
what are the margin calls
that we need to make
because there were some
bad, you know, somebody,
some other customers or
clients made bad trades.
Like that's a risk decision
that's really critical for a big bank.
So if we get that wrong,
how do we make sure that we enable
the learning that goes with that.
So with cyber we have things go wrong.
How do we get to the root
cause of what happened
and simultaneously be pressed forward?
One other quick point,
and I absolutely infinitely
respect the VC community
and the comments that Sam made.
I would also just offer a
counter and a flip side to it.
Even in the previous, there
was a question around,
you know, VC, we hold up
the word in the military,
we just kind of munged
VC with private equity.
Be careful because the VC world
is not usually enterprise grade software.
I'm a huge proponent of feeding that
into the Department of Defense,
the national security
community, et cetera.
We have to have that.
However come you don't often
find SOC2 compliant software
in the VC space.
And so as you look to proliferate
where we need to go as a
national security community,
you have to make sure you connect back
to enterprise grade software
that's going to be able
to do well at scale
and it's not different
than the cyber firms Ted.
- Well, I mean to your point, you know,
there needs to be accountability, right?
If DIU vendor is developing a product
that SOCOM is buying and it doesn't work
as we heard in the previous session,
there needs to be accountability
for that with that vendor.
That's where the procurement policy making
is so crucial that because these are
nat sec level type of
threats that we're facing,
and if that product
were to fail with a unit
in a deployed, in a foreign
enemy territory, wow.
That kind of thing.
And to your point, VCs are absolutely,
they're looking at first go-to-market,
et cetera, that kind of thing.
And they're not taking their
cutting corners in a way.
But that's why, you know,
the technical evaluation
board needs to be just as
where I have to say ATL is leading
in a lot of ways with procurement
and devising new mechanisms
to provide that best technical
value to the war fighter
and holding folks accountable too.
And they're doing that by
bringing in industry experts
to actually examine that product
that it, they're, you know,
as a third party, not them,
they're bringing in some
professor and saying,
hey sir, can you analyze this?
- And can I jump on that?
- Yeah, please.
- If I'm in Bill's role,
the thing that I really
wanna make sure is happening
is you have two types of testing
before you roll something out.
There's quality engineering, QE testing,
making sure is the engineering
have you run all the combinations
and permutations of what can go wrong.
And that is often short stroked
in any product company.
'Cause you get compressed
and you're like late
and that's the last step and you're like,
oh my gosh, how can we do
what we're supposed to do in
four weeks in just a week?
I do that just to be clear,
and I get pushed against the wall
and sometimes I need to
make a hard decision.
Do we miss our deadline or do we say,
nope, we're gonna test for four weeks.
Sometimes I choose one,
sometimes I choose the other.
But the other part of it
that often gets overlooked
is UAT, user acceptance testing.
And so going back to your customers,
your clients and saying,
all right, before we
really harden this product,
we want your feedback from
a consumer perspective.
And don't forget the DoD,
the national security community
is a consumer that can drive
the development of products.
- And field testing too.
Where is it going to be deployed?
Will that product work
in that deployment area?
That is not happening
and we'll get better.
- [Ted] Let's open it up to questions
and thoughts from the audience.
- Come on, it's about my coat kerchief.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] What is
AI dusty, can I have some.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] I'll ask a question.
- [Ted] Oh, we'll get both of you.
Go ahead. Yeah.
- [Audience Member] I
was just gonna ask Mike,
can you say anything
more about the project
that you led that involved the structured
and unstructured data,
and reconceiving that
or restructuring that across the company?
- I can, and I'll be quick
and glad to take it offline.
The VMware is a 25 year old enterprise.
What happens for...
I'll talk about VMware,
but it's also metaphorically
any large enterprise,
I don't care if you're Amazon, Google,
Microsoft, whatever,
you have tangled knots
sometimes in these enterprises that are,
have just been created
because number one is
success can create an ability
to just go buy the next
thing and layer it on.
And the proverbial spaghetti plate
just gets more and more
larger and more tangled.
And so for us, we never stepped back
and actually like really
created the governance
around our data.
And we had poor hierarchy,
meaning what lives where in what ecosystem
and how do you get after that?
And so what we operate.
Number one is we created
a vision for a new world.
We ran on the old world.
And then there's a lot of
tension in any organization
to say, why aren't you
paying attention to me
'cause I need more
paperclips and chewing gum
to go run the old stuff.
You have to swing...
I have limited, you know,
a finite amount of resources people
to either run the company
or transform the company.
So I need to make a decision.
How much allocation do I spend toward run
and toward transform.
The simple math problem the
more you put on transform,
the faster you're gonna do it,
but the louder the complaints
are gonna be around the run.
And so, you know, I
tried to get that right
over the last couple years.
Sometimes I got it right,
sometimes I got it wrong.
But where we popped out on the other side
was a modern data architecture
with incredible governance and hierarchy
so that now we can really benefit
from the things that Dr.
Krishnan is talking about
and sitting on top of models
that can say, you know,
look at what's a customer's
propensity to buy.
They already have product number A,
are they gonna buy product C, F or L?
And these are the kinds of things
that can ultimately help us
drive more top line revenue
or save costs and therefore
improve the bottom line.
But why is that important
for the national security community?
It's because think about the
world in a GDP framework.
Remember it's just
labor times productivity
equals the total economic
output of the world.
You know, there are a lot of us in here
with incredible pasts and you know,
at the end of the day though
we are largely commodities
where our government can go buy more of us
if they have more money.
A lot of us are very
expensive commodities,
but we're commodities nonetheless.
And so more GDP equals more capacity
for our nation to create more, you know,
special people like in this room,
or to pay down debt or
to buy more healthcare,
more education, more whatever.
And so driving productivity for the nation
really is job number one.
- Just make a quick comment to follow up.
One of the biggest challenges
with the structured
and unstructured data is,
traditionally our view is
this data is being used
to train models to,
for "good purposes".
But these data can also
be subject to manipulation
and become a type of a vector for attack.
So you could have an adversary change
or change the nature of your corpus,
or inject stuff into your corpus
that then gets your model
to behave differently
than you would want it to.
Or the model itself is something that
is subject to potential attack.
So that's why I think the
system's view of the problem
is really important to take
rather than just look at one
algorithm or what the data is,
you need to go all the way
from problem formulation
to data, to the methods,
all the way out to what
comes out on the other side.
- Can I ask you a question?
Is that legal?
- Of course.
- How do you know when it's broken down?
- So the big question here
is when you have this,
this is where you have to have,
if you have ground truth,
meaning you know, in some
cases what the ground truth is,
then the question is
when there is variance
is there a way in which you can check back
as to why the model is not
working like it's supposed to?
In the case where you
don't have ground truth,
this becomes a hugely challenging problem.
But this data contamination problem,
which is the problem we are talking about,
where you have an adversary attacking
the data sets that you're training on,
itself is something that
you can bootstrap your AI
around and ask the question
and is the data contaminated or not?
It doesn't have to be a binary thing,
that's itself is a subjective,
it's a topic of study.
- Well, I mean data manipulation
is so crucial these days
just because in the outside
world we're seeing the rise of
deep fakes and everything
that's happening right now,
and tools are so important
to effectively corroborate
that report if that is happening
or this is a fake report
or is this a real report?
What is happening and what
are the actual core sources
that it's being reported from?
Because there's so much
haziness and fuzziness
that's happening on
the news and what's on.
My dad is on Facebook and he is like,
"Did you see this report?"
I'm like, "Dad, no. Stop".
You know, it's just one of those things
because there's so much
misinformation being pumped
by state actors but also
commercial actors as well too.
So that is something we need be cognizant.
- The challenge that Sam speaks about
I think is when you have
this type of misinformation
getting pumped into the system,
and that gets then added
back into the corpus.
Then you get the training of these models
being affected by what's been added in.
- Well, like the hallucination of ChatGPT.
- That could be for altogether different.
- Sure.
(both laughing)
It hallucinates for others.
- Yeah. But ChatGPT is just,
it's putting a response back
in a very nice language,
but it's also taking rument
as well that's out there
from forums, et cetera, whatever,
and saying, hey, this is
actually what's going on.
No, that is not,
because right now in the bottom
when that prompt does appear,
you don't see any sources, right?
But we're gonna see ChatGPT also evolve.
Right now it's text space
where you're reading it
and you're analyzing it,
but in like six months
or a year or whatever,
you're gonna see a full
video production of...
I was joking earlier, professor
Girvin's, six years of,
you know, lectures all
condensed into one hour
with a AI developed Professor Girvin.
So it is just one of those things.
It's going to be revolutionary,
but there also needs
to be some safeguards,
guardrails around it.
And I know some countries are doing that.
I mean some countries have already,
Italy I think was just ban ChatGPT.
But it's just, you know,
that's where policy needs to catch up.
- [Ted] Thank you. There
was one other question here
and then we'll get to wrap up.
- [Dave] Hi Dave Jewel from J Seven.
Bear with me for just a minute.
So a lot of the things you
came up comes into mind
as an old planner, as an
educator, as a researcher.
And the secretary brought up
the morning about war gaming
in the department usually starts
after deterrence has failed
where sauce value is not the same
as we propose it is prior to that.
Done hundreds of types
of war games in business.
Most of them that we use in the work,
most of them are based
on correlation of forces
and means some sort of attrition
model of combat forces.
So that clear data, clear logic,
so we can get to Mike's
opinions based on good research.
In the conflict, the contest for influence
in spaces such as we were
talking about disinformation,
so MISO or PSYOPs information
support operations
or civil affairs or
expeditionary medicine.
Is anybody doing this 'cause I don't know.
And if so, how can we tap
into it using the tools of AI
and machine learning to
collect the data we have
to include at some level
the excursion into some
percentage that is misinformation
to apply the logic with those parameters
that the decision makers set
so you can reduce the
ambiguity to a decision.
One movement that I'm
watching with fascination now
is a lot of bespoke war gaming
in war gaming communities attributed with
some of our PME institutions everything.
And they're fascinating,
but they operate almost
entirely in the opinion world.
War game designer makes rules,
makes a good presentation of it,
and thinkers go in and
bring their experience
and their wisdom to it,
and come out with what they do.
We learn lessons from that
for military planning.
But how can we use AI to take what is a
combat attrition model in conflict
like the old movie "War Games"
and apply it to in the
space to the left of
battle for influence with partners
and against adversaries.
- So right now you asked,
the first thing was that,
are we doing this right now?
The office of net
assessments in the Pentagon,
they are doing this.
They have a pilot program
that they're working with
IARPA and DARPA right now
that it's being developed
in such a way where
it's examining all the war gamings
that have happened with
academic institutions,
Columbia, et cetera.
And they're compiling all of that data
and seeing how countries
have reacted in the past
and how they will react with the current
core technology capability they may have,
and what the investments are.
It's still in pilot phase right now,
but I'll get with you offline
and share some additional data with you.
- [Dave] Thank you sir.
That's in the office of net assessment
that's not over the J Seven world
of the more traditional folks.
Yeah. Great. I'm excited
and interested in that.
I was hoping you answer--
- [Ted] Dr. Krishnan final thoughts.
Any ideas on use of AI for simulations,
war games or maybe complex decision making
that might occur in the future
that might help us think
about strategic challenges?
- Absolutely. Including the
context that you raised.
So conditional on having crisp definitions
of what misinformation is.
Because what's misinformation
to you might be just,
you know, good information to me.
So as long as we have crisp definitions
of what misinformation is, then I think
the challenging issue really is
that we now have technology
in particular again
using these large language models
that currently have been
created and made popular.
They have two elements to them.
The first part is what's
called a transformer.
The second part's what's
called a adaptive fine tuner.
The adaptive fine tuner is
designed usually to take bias
and toxicity out of the language model.
But that same technique
can be used to amp up
the kinds of messages I could send
to a populace to manipulate them
to get max influence over them.
In other words, I create
different messages,
run it by humans and figure out
which messages have the most
capacity to influence somebody.
So what we then have is a machinery then
that has economies of scale and scope
in terms of being able to
send out over a network.
So if you control some kind of a,
so if you take TikTok or a Facebook
or an Instagram or any of these kinds
of social media platforms,
you have the capacity to
flood these with messages.
And it doesn't have to be just text.
It could be to Sam's
point, it could be audio,
it could be video.
And I think we have a very
interesting case study coming up.
I think I was in a earlier presentation,
where seems to be multiple
elections coming up
in multiple countries, including our own.
So I think you're gonna see
a very significant amping up
of the extent of misinformation
and disinformation being
deployed on the internet.
And I think it behooves us all,
I think to do three things.
I think one of course is, you know,
better technology to try and identify
and classify and take out and
weed out this misinformation.
The question is who's liable for it?
You know, where does the
incentive like to remove that?
That's one.
The second I think has to
do with educating people to,
as Sam was pointing out,
don't believe everything
what you see on the internet.
That's a long run kind of effort.
And then the third is
being able to sort of
take these types of, you know,
this is gonna be core to our democracy.
So do you think about content labeling?
Just like when you buy wine
you know it comes from
California or from Italy.
Should content that
comes from an AI engine
be actually watermarked?
Should it require content labeling?
Should there be peer evaluation?
You know what I mean?
Wine spectator says that bottle is a 93
and that bottle is an 89.
So should you have peer
reviews of content?
So there are lots of
different policy approaches
one could think about as
well in addition to this,
but it's a hugely complex problem
and I don't think
there's an easy solution.
And we've been dealing with this now for,
it's getting close to a decade
and we don't have really good
purely technical solutions
because this is a socio-technical problem,
it's not a technical problem alone.
So any solution's gonna have to be
a sociotechnical solution.
- [Ted] Absolutely.
Please join me in thanking our panelists.
(audience applauding)
(subtle music)